hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play followed by death
ok we went into this rather warm and
inviting looking room and I bet that's
all gonna change
what's that close yep it's not gonna
stay warm for long here my memory
scooting Rafferty's continuous again I
can't remember back at home to hell
anymore and I return I'll have to tell
my brother I'm sorry he's a good brother
in not a thief I want to be friends with
him again against the pressure of my
past is starting to burden me once more
that's my best Finnish accent ooh ha Oki
mystery pop and then it here no bang
bang bang bang bang
nothing mmm it's too too nice in here
way too nice way too nice I don't
yes oil laudanum um all right
oh hello all right then cool that was
something wait was there something out
there that I could have gone legit
ah okay I got you whoo that's a nice
view all right
film grain is more than I noticed before
probably goes it's actually day to look
daylight so I can see the film grain all
right continuing along Ariel
ah oh yeah so tough that hurt me wow
that hurt me I would wax recorder violin
deleted rowdy
nothing in there all right
for hello do you really think it's true
can we somehow can you help the rich off
between curse quite possibly Ingrid
Francis on our side we'll figure out
something
what ran berries okay I can't go further
down don't trust him
feels like he's not the same man not the
same man I knew once I once knew
yep music is too nice everything's just
too nice something I must dance yeah
Frank Frank come on break it sorry
broken hog a book I do that guy Hinds um
fines up Haydn's up a blood stain
special oh okay here booth and broke
your crap char yeah I'm sorry broken
someone must have came here before me
and decided to smash up the place cuz
that's what any honored guests would do
whose life was just saved by these
strange people ah here we go
what do we got here um come on dear we
all Newton ah being in the company of
Francis has always been beneficial but
he seems to be too eager to in his plans
as of late I can't help but think he'll
lead us all to her this Henry was always
really been very loyal to Francis in
what question his hors d'oeuvres I don't
understand his motives energy and every
even turns his eye toward us or even
such a world
unless Francis around I think he's
hiding something friend Henry and
Francis both but as for me and David
we'll stop those two if they even tried
to double-cross us yes the world is full
of double-crossers another nice view hmm
I didn't think the view distance in this
game was that far that's pretty nice
well done well done gang oh hello it's
dark
oh what's this ah one of the books maybe
aha
probably I mean it is a library so it
would make sense that one of these books
might remote-control it don't see any I
don't see any books that stand out
that's blocked up nothing in here all
right
there's nothing well there's probably
something I can't see you right now
ah crap it's it's got to be here okay
wait I see something I see something
come here
ha ha oh yeah got it did I get it Dec
get it
nope okay maybe there was another one in
here somewhere um you know okay let's
see I don't hear any tick ticking it's
just pulled so maybe there's another one
around here somewhere
Oh what the hell gotta be another one
right
maybe I'm just mistaken maybe all that
did was unlock something in the other
room where I was what hello
aha another fake book out of this one ah
oh ah okay let's try that then this one
and then the other one so I found all
three books Hot Diggity
okay no okay let's try this one and then
the one closest to the door and then the
middle one brute force baby love it love
my brute force nope okay let's try
middle this'n and then the outer
there's only one more peer mediation
left flunk that do it
oh now the middle sorry damn it
thought I pulled the middle point huh
I'm confused
yeah let's spend the whole episode just
trying to guess this combination huh
yeah uh who's the man is broken by a key
key off is key on the breast oh so great
hey I expected all the lamps to go out
like just boom Olsen Dirk it's still
bright and sunshiny day look at this
beautiful ah whoa hey careful now
it's gorgeous sun is shining I didn't
even know the sunshine could shine in
this game it's beautiful all right up
okay
huh all right there we go Oh what was
that
ha ha ha
damn it I'll have you have you have you
I'm chair all right going out the window
not down and um go away go away go away
I hear ya why did I uh I heard the damn
I heard the damn thing I didn't I didn't
open the door
or I shouldn't have opened the door
alright alright
he's still there no okay I have that
chair reset position what the hell I
threw this chair you're all sorry
ah don't trust you
sorry buddy you may have been a noble
knight at one point but now you're just
a monster waiting to attack I have the
key funk watch out
peeps Oh block that cheer up door block
that door up chair Wow
I messed up alright it's not even dark
in here I mean it there's no windows but
it's still pretty full hello hi you do
you you son of a [ __ ] yeah your crowbar
ah
you coming this way
can a crowbar my way out of here Oh
nobody aah
Oh what I do go good
hide me bare I'm not here oh I see okay
I got stack up before it comes it's
probably like right there I'm so boned
but whatever patiently stacking up I
obviously can't go back okay maybe the
crowbar oh come on I see it right here I
can't use it what the hell all right
whatever I guess I'll go this way
bring it on monster hello anyone anyone
hello
hello okay
very gingerly go by this window okay how
did it get through the door if it just
punched a hole in it that is the
question
oh hello it's so quiet
momento although just once
I'm just skedaddle bye
that was so creepy was so bright you
know so freaked out still it's just
you're just creepy
the castle is haunting me it's dark past
will soon be revealed
I am unnerved
I am perturbed ah mark goob
okay I keep thinking that I have a
button that can like show me a waypoint
like dead space could to near all good
Lord ease that where it came from his oh
I don't remember where I came from
well me personally I came why hey this
stuff um I think I came out that way
didn't I didn't I come up here I've
totally forgotten lazy they said the
tunnels I think I came in through the
tunnel so let me go this other way
you know likey what
I won't budge okay that's that's okay I
I don't need it to budge maybe that was
the way I came let me just pop in the
tunnels here for a second see if
thousand-point Francis was in front
leading the group alongside with Henry
William whispered to David's ear just
play along no sorry
just play along that's it that's the
most threatening Swedes can be you're
Finnish people Cheers
play along sorry sorry
those insulting okay maybe I haven't
been this way before it sure is dark
though I love it being dark okay now
it's nice and warm
not necessarily warm but right oh hello
damn you darkness the slimy red goo apt
description very well-versed ah
that's what the girl Bosworth monk yeah
come on Oh everyone knows grunting makes
you stronger
oh that's how I get so swole pumping
iron in the gym gum beast so tough den
the box ah thank you for the little
sunlight no no no
it was there what the hell what the hell
what dear hell
well don't have a chemistry pot ha ha
get out it oh yeah nobody come in here
come in there don't worry everybody
uh uh uh don't look at me don't look at
me I'm not here buddy
you cook it the lid you feel it hello-oh
eyes coming back coming back he's coming
not today buddy and today no today Oh
Brent run run I'll go faster buddy ok ok
ok gonna cause a damn dark I got him hey
acid pour it in the pudding pudding
pudding ah come on
there we go ok oh I think I made it hike
we're right back oh well I guess that'll
keep monsters out of my way okay
oh I thought I'd gotten away from that
guy just came right back in the room ok
thank you guys so much for watching
that's all the time I got for this
episode though thanks again for watching
and I will see you in the next part
bye bye